the neoliberals freaked out over their precious equilibrium.
"If you raise the price of labor," they warned,
"businesses will purchase less of it.
Thousands of low-wage workers will lose their jobs.
The restaurants will close."
Except ...
they didn't.
The unemployment rate fell dramatically.
The restaurant business in Seattle boomed.
Why?
Because there is no equilibrium.
Because raising wages doesn't kill jobs, it creates them;
because, for instance,
when restaurant owners are suddenly required to pay restaurant workers enough
so that now even they can afford to eat in restaurants,
it doesn't shrink the restaurant business,
it grows it, obviously.
(Applause)
Thank you.
The second assumption is
that the price of something is always equal to its value,
which basically means that if you earn 50,000 dollars a year
and I earn 50 million dollars a year,
that's because I produce a thousand times as much value as you.
Now,
it will not surprise you to learn
that this is a very comforting assumption
if you're a CEO paying yourself 50 million dollars a year
but paying your workers poverty wages.
But please, take it from somebody who has run dozens of businesses:
this is nonsense.
People are not paid what they are worth.
They are paid what they have the power to negotiate,
and wages' falling share of GDP
is not because workers have become less productive
but because employers have become more powerful.
And --
(Applause)
And by pretending that the giant imbalance in power between capital and labor
doesn't exist,
neoliberal economic theory became essentially
a protection racket for the rich.
The third assumption, and by far the most pernicious,
is a behavioral model
that describes human beings as something called "homo economicus,"
which basically means that we are all perfectly selfish,
perfectly rational and relentlessly self-maximizing.
But just ask yourselves,
is it plausible that every single time for your entire life,
when you did something nice for somebody else,
all you were doing was maximizing your own utility?
Is it plausible that when a soldier jumps on a grenade to defend fellow soldiers,
they're just promoting their narrow self-interest?
If you think that's nuts,
contrary to any reasonable moral intuition,
that's because it is
and, according to the latest science,
not true.
But it is this behavioral model
which is at the cold, cruel heart of neoliberal economics,
and it is as morally corrosive
as it is scientifically wrong
because, if we accept at face value
that humans are fundamentally selfish,
and then we look around the world
at all of the unambiguous prosperity in it,
then it follows logically,
then it must be true by definition,
that billions of individual acts of selfishness
magically transubstantiate into prosperity and the common good.
If we humans are merely selfish maximizers,
then selfishness is the cause of our prosperity.
Under this economic logic,
greed is good,
widening inequality is efficient,
and the only purpose of the corporation
can be to enrich shareholders,
because to do otherwise would be to slow economic growth
and harm the economy overall.
And it is this gospel of selfishness
which forms the ideological cornerstone of neoliberal economics,
a way of thinking which has produced economic policies
which have enabled me and my rich buddies in the top one percent
to grab virtually all of the benefits of growth over the last 40 years.
But,
if instead
we accept the latest empirical research,
real science, which correctly describes human beings
as highly cooperative,
reciprocal
and intuitively moral creatures,
then it follows logically
that it must be cooperation
and not selfishness
that is the cause of our prosperity,
and it isn't our self-interest
but rather our inherent reciprocity
that is humanity's economic superpower.
So at the heart of this new economics
is a story about ourselves that grants us permission to be our best selves,
and, unlike the old economics,
this is a story that is virtuous
and also has the virtue of being true.
Now,
I want to emphasize that this new economics
is not something I have personally imagined or invented.
Its theories and models are being developed and refined
in universities around the world
building on some of the best new research in economics,
complexity theory, evolutionary theory,
psychology, anthropology and other disciplines.
And although this new economics does not yet have its own textbook
or even a commonly agreed upon name,
in broad strokes
its explanation of where prosperity comes from goes something like this.
So, market capitalism is an evolutionary system
in which prosperity emerges
through a positive feedback loop
between increasing amounts of innovation and increasing amounts of consumer demand.
Innovation is the process by which we solve human problems,
consumer demand is the mechanism through which the market selects
for useful innovations,
and as we solve more problems, we become more prosperous.
But as we become more prosperous,
our problems and solutions
become more complex,
and this increasing technical complexity
requires ever higher levels of social and economic cooperation
in order to produce the more highly specialized products
that define a modern economy.
Now, the old economics is correct, of course,
that competition plays a crucial role in how markets work,
but what it fails to see
is that it is largely a competition between highly cooperative groups --
competition between firms, competition between networks of firms,
competition between nations --
and anyone who has ever run a successful business knows
that building a cooperative team by including the talents of everyone
is almost always a better strategy than just a bunch of selfish jerks.
So how do we leave neoliberalism behind
and build a more sustainable, more prosperous
and more equitable society?
The new economics suggests just five rules of thumb.
First is that successful economies are not jungles, they're gardens,
which is to say that markets,
like gardens, must be tended,
that the market is the greatest social technology ever invented
for solving human problems,
but unconstrained by social norms or democratic regulation,
markets inevitably create more problems than they solve.
Climate change,
the great financial crisis of 2008
are two easy examples.
The second rule is
that inclusion creates economic growth.
So the neoliberal idea
that inclusion is this fancy luxury
to be afforded if and when we have growth is both wrong and backwards.
The economy is people.
Including more people in more ways
is what causes economic growth in market economies.
The third principle
is the purpose of the corporation is not merely to enrich shareholders.
The greatest grift in contemporary economic life
is the neoliberal idea that the only purpose of the corporation
and the only responsibility of executives
is to enrich themselves and shareholders.
The new economics must and can insist
that the purpose of the corporation
is to improve the welfare of all stakeholders:
customers, workers,
community and shareholders alike.
Rule four:
greed is not good.
Being rapacious doesn't make you a capitalist,
it makes you a sociopath.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
And in an economy as dependent upon cooperation at scale as ours,
sociopathy is as bad for business as it is for society.
And fifth and finally,
unlike the laws of physics,
the laws of economics are a choice.
Now, neoliberal economic theory
has sold itself to you as unchangeable natural law,
when in fact it's social norms and constructed narratives
based on pseudoscience.
If we truly want a more equitable,
more prosperous and more sustainable economy,
if we want high-functioning democracies
and civil society,
we must have a new economics.
And here's the good news:
if we want a new economics,
all we have to do is choose to have it.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Moderator: So Nick, I'm sure you get this question a lot.
If you're so unhappy with the economic system,
why not just give all your money away and join the 99 percent?
Nick Hanauer: Yeah, no, yes, right.
You get that a lot. You get that a lot.
"If you care so much about taxes, why don't you pay more,
and if you care so much about wages, why don't you pay more?"
And I could do that.
The problem is,
it doesn't make that much difference,
and I have discovered a strategy
that works literally a hundred thousand times better --
Moderator: OK.
NH: which is to use my money to build narratives and to pass laws
that will require all the other rich people
to pay taxes and pay their workers better.
(Applause)
And so, for example,
the 15-dollar minimum wage that we cooked up
has now affected 30 million workers.
So that works better.
Moderator: That's great.
If you change your mind, we'll find some takers for you.
NH: OK. Thank you. Moderator: Thank you very much.